in a related development the nra
immediately filed suit today to block a
new gun control law just signed by the
governor of Florida Governor Scott so
after reviewing the entire bill I had to
ask myself well this bill make a huge
investment and dramatically improve
school safety and hopes have never seen
another tragedy like this again
well this bill provide more funding to
treat the mentally ill well this bill
give far more tools to keep guns away
from people who should not have them the
answer to all three is yes not everyone
thinks the answer is yes and joining me
former Orlando is Republican congressman
Ron de santis Ron and I served in the
United States Congress together we're on
the same Oversight Committee as well as
the Judiciary Committee he is also now
running for the governor of Florida so
congressman DeSantis thanks so much for
joining us hey Jason good to see you so
the governor signed a bill would you if
you were elected governor would you have
signed that bill I think I would have
approached it a little bit different I
think certainly the school security I
think is long overdue the money for
mental health and then being able to
identify these individuals who are
dangerous so that they're not able to
possess weapons I think all those are
good I think when you start getting into
some of the blanket restrictions on
people's Second Amendment rights I think
that that is constitutionally vulnerable
I think those lawsuits are probably
going to succeed I mean think about it
you have an enumerated right in the Bill
of Rights there's really no precedent to
just do a blanket ban on certain adults
I mean we wouldn't say that if you're 18
to 20 you don't have a Fourth Amendment
right and police could search your house
without a warrant we wouldn't say that
they could seize your property without
just compensation and that the Fifth
Amendment doesn't apply so I think that
was problematic I don't think that
provision will actually prevent any any
gun crimes but here's the thing and you
know more than anybody and dealing on
the oversight you worked we worked
together for years
this between the locals in Broward
County and between the federal with the
FBI was the most catastrophic failure of
government that I've witnessed since
I've been in the Congress or when I
served in the military you
guys mentioned the different warnings
that were given on the scene
obviously they went to the guy's house
23 times they had ample opportunity to
arrest him they didn't do it we then got
a briefing this week in Washington from
the FBI
not only did they get a great tip in
January not only did they get a tip the
previous year 2017 in Mississippi the
caller in 2018 who took it on the FBI
actually connected the two to the
Mississippi one so they knew this guy
was dangerous and they made a decision
not even to alert the local authorities
and so we can argue about different laws
the fact is the laws that were on the
books were sufficient to prevent this
had government done its job
now one of the provisions in there is
two in Florida and it's available in
other states or instance in Utah there
are teachers and school officials who
can carry weapons are you in favor of
that do you think that would help
I would not mandate any teachers to to
carry or administrators well what I
would do is say a school should not be
advertised as a quote gun-free zone if
you have maybe it's just one or two
faculty members who are licensed who
have a concealed carry permit I don't
think they should be prohibited from
using that bringing the the firearm in a
concealed way on campus and the reason
is even if no one decides to do it just
the fact that it might be there I think
that gives a potential shooter pause and
if you're beefing up the outside
security and you're hardening the
schools then guess what the schools are
no longer such an inviting target I mean
we've kind of let these things be
sitting ducks and there's a sickness in
society with some of these really
demented individuals that are attracted
to that I think just saying that a
concealed carry permit holder can go to
campus and teach or instruct with that I
think that would serve as a deterrent
for people to view that as a viable
target congressman Ron de santis in
Orlando thank you for joining us